One of the scariest moments of my career
started on a dark October morning in 2018.
I’m a professional athlete,
and my training schedule can be a lot.
Six days a week, five hours a day.
It's intense.
Still, I never train that early.
But on this day,
a special type of fear
brought me out at 4am before the sun.
A fear that someone might discover
a secret I'd been keeping.
I was six months pregnant.
I was pregnant, and I was scared
enough to train in the dark
so that no one would see the life
that was growing inside of me.
I feared that if a fan
or someone posted a photo,
that my sponsor would immediately
change their mind
about wanting to work with me.
I feared that I would be forced
to choose between motherhood
and being a competitive athlete.
I feared that the career
I worked so hard to build
would disappear just like that.
You think I'm exaggerating, right?
How could a six-time Olympic champion,
a 16-time world champion,
a world record holder,
possibly think that her career
might be over by doing something
as natural as having a baby?
Well, I'm not exaggerating.
Getting pregnant in track and field
has been called the “kiss of death.”
And it comes with a lot of fear,
just like for women in many professions.
I have been watching women that I respect
and teammates of mine hide pregnancies
since I was 19 years old.
I've seen women have to make
gut-wrenching decisions
like deciding whether
to recover their health
or return to the sport.
Deciding whether to stay in the hospital
with a sick child or go to a race
so that they don't receive
a further pay reduction.
I know what some of you might be thinking.
We all choose to get pregnant, right?
If a sponsor doesn't want
to pay an athlete
who's not out on the track winning,
that's just part of the deal, right?
Well, I think the deal's rigged.
I think that companies want
to have it both ways.
And I think it's time we change.
Sports companies love to tell women
that they can have it all.
They can do it all, they can be it all.
We've all seen those inspirational ads.
I remember meeting
with Nike leadership in 2010,
and they told me about an initiative
they sponsored called the Girl Effect.
They promoted adolescent girls
as the key to improving societies
around the globe.
They said they believed
in women and girls.
And if I joined Nike,
I could empower them.
And I believed that.
But guess what?
Girls come from somewhere.
(Laughter)
And women having babies
during childrearing years
is something that should be
celebrated, not punished.
It should be a part of a normal, thriving,
professional, athletic career.
And women in all fields
should never feel the need
to hide a pregnancy, at 4am, in the dark,
so that they won't be photographed
doing that thing that they love.
Thank you.
(Applause)
Remember how scared I told you I was
when I was on the track that day?
My mind was racing with the consequences
of my decision to start a family.
I had already been going through
a difficult renegotiation
period with Nike,
and they were already
offering me 70 percent less
than what I had previously been making.
And that was even before
they knew about the baby.
Don't even get me started with the ageism
that is embedded in the capitalist dream.
So when I told them about my pregnancy,
I asked for a clause in the contract
that specified they wouldn't reduce my pay
within 12 months of giving birth.
They said yes.
But -- you knew there
was going to be a "but", right?
But it was only a yes for me.
They weren't ready to offer that same
protection for all female athletes.
They weren't ready to set the precedent.
A couple of days later,
my agent called me.
Nike wanted to use me in a commercial
for the Women's World Cup.
I couldn't believe it.
Nike wanted to use me
to tell women and girls
that they could do anything,
even though the contract before me
said the exact opposite.
I knew what I had to do.
I knew I had to leave.
I knew I was afraid,
but I did it anyways.
I wrote an op-ed in "The New York Times"
calling out Nike's maternity policy,
and I wasn't the only one.
(Applause)
My teammates and I,
we helped turn the tide.
Now, Nike offers eighteen months
maternity protection
and other sponsors --
(Applause)
And other sponsors like Altra,
Nuun, Brooks and Burton,
they came forward and they announced
their new guarantees for female athletes
who start families while being sponsored.
Too late for me,
but amazing for the women coming up now.
I didn't resign with Nike,
and I'm here to tell the tale.
But more than that,
I'm here to tell you
that you can do it, too.
Once you find the courage
to believe in yourself,
your own worth, your own values,
it gets easier.
It's when you take a stand
that you start to understand
how to overcome that fear
and how to make a change for yourself
and sometimes for others.
I went on to find a new sponsor
in the female-led, female-focused Athleta,
and they helped me --
(Applause)
And they helped me challenge
the International Olympic
Committee's childcare policy.
Together, we raised 200,000 dollars
for female athletes to be able to afford
childcare when they go to races.
Because women have babies,
and these children don't disappear
when the races begin.
I made it back to the Olympics
two years after giving birth.
I won a gold and a bronze.
(Applause and cheers)
And I became the most decorated American
track and field athlete of all time.
All while my daughter was watching.
Audience: Aww.
AF: I was running for so much more
than for medals
or for a time on the track.
I was running as a representation
for women and for mothers
and for anybody who had been told
that their story was over.
I remember crossing that line in Tokyo
and having such a sense of fulfillment.
I looked down at my feet
and for the first time
in my entire career,
I wasn't wearing Adidas,
I wasn't wearing Nike.
I was wearing Saysh,
the women's footwear brand that I founded,
designed for and by women,
when I was left without
a footwear sponsor.
Because I was tired of not being valued
or able to show up fully as myself.
I learned that my voice has power,
and when I bet on myself,
change is possible.
During the pandemic,
we all saw what happens
when that thin line
between our professional
and personal lives permanently blurs.
We have seen women step back,
give up, drop out,
as having it all became doing it all,
and doing it all became impossible.
We have got to stop forcing people
to choose between parenting
and doing the work that they love.
And we've got to stop pretending
that we're not making those decisions
because the results affect us all.
Not just women, but men
and our children, too.
By creating the environment
that we all live, work,
love and raise our families in.
Isn't it past time
that we call out the hypocrisy
and create a new normal?
One with real generosity,
humanity and truth at the center,
not some misplaced sense
of what business is or does.
We should say what we will tolerate.
And as we all recover from the pandemic
that has flattened us,
let's just not rebuild the same version
of the broken system that we had before.
But let's learn and create something new.
Each one of us has a role to play.
And you don’t have to be an Olympian
to create change
for yourself or for others.
Everyone in this room
can bet on themselves.
It will typically happen
in moments of fear
when you don't see the path forward.
In my own experience,
it was a terrifying decision,
but that will be your first clue.
That feeling of being terrified
is your invitation to create change.
You have to acknowledge those feelings,
you have to brave them,
and you have to fight to move forward.
It won't be easy.
You will be afraid.
Your voice will shake.
But what I can absolutely promise you
is that it will be worth it.
Thank you.
(Applause)